[Musique]
bonjour à tous je suis très content
deux des trois avec vous pour des
raisons propres à aujourd'hui en fait
assez particulière je suis même très
très content d'être avec vous alors je
vais vous expliquer comment la pensée
enfin la pensée une certaine façon de
penser d'interroger le réel de poser des
questions permet en effet d'aller au
delà des limites du monde empirique du
monde observable tir du monde tel qu'il
nous est déjà donné l'exemple sur lequel
je pourrai m'appuyer c'est albert
einstein
mais avant d'évoquer le père de la
relativité je vous ai parlé un petit peu
des swaps et les big data dont vous
entendez beaucoup parler et dont vous
savez qu'elle change déjà nos vies nos
façons de travailler
et certains pensent qu'elles vont aussi
changer notre façon de faire de la
science
beaucoup pensent que au lieu de
théoriser nous allons céder aux
facilités de l'induction
c'est à dire nous allons observer des
régularités de comportement par exemple
du trafic automobile par exemple les
consommateurs du climat de la météo des
indices économiques et c est à partir de
ces régularités nous affairons des lois
que nous considérons comme général voire
universel alors même qu'elle ne referons
que condensé ce qui a déjà été donnée et
donc au lieu de théoriser on ne pourrait
plus plaisir parce que comme vous l'avez
observé au xxème siècle grâce des
théories physiques par exemple on a été
capable de prédire l'existence de
nouvelles sortes d'éléments de réalité
par exemple grâce aux équations la
physique des particules
on était capable de prédire l'existence
du boson de higgs
cette particule qui a été détecté pour
la première fois en 2012 grâce aux
équations d'einstein de la gravitation
on a été capable de prédire l'existence
des ondes gravitationnelles qui ont été
détectés cette année c'est à dire un
siècle
après leur reddition en 1916 par
einstein et donc l'épitaphe ont
évidemment une opportunité fantastique
mais elle risque de nous conduire à ne
regarder que des corrélations des
corrélations entre les données qui sont
disponibles or une corrélation
ce n'est pas la même chose qu'une
relation de cause à effet ce n'est pas
parce qu'il ya des grenouilles
après la pluie qu'on a le droit de dire
qu'il a plus les grenouilles
alors maintenant j'en viens à einstein
lui-même 1915 einstein publié un papier
même plusieurs dans lesquelles ils
développent une nouvelle théorie de la
gravitation universelle complètement
révolutionnaire avec des équations donc
y sont associés à cette théorie est
cette théorie est un siècle plus tard
celle que nous continuons d'utiliser
pour faire de la cosmologie scientifique
c'est à dire que les innombrables
données recueillies depuis un siècle par
les satellites dans les télescopes etc
n'ont jamais obligé à remettre en cause
les équations d'einstein
or que savons que savait-on de l'univers
en 1915 en fait rien on ne savait pas
qu'il existait d'autres galaxie que la
nôtre on ne savait pas d'où vient que
les étoiles brillent
on n'allait pas encore repéré des forces
nucléaires on ne savait évidemment pas
que l'univers est en expansion et en
guise d' objets célestes
on ne connaissait guère que les étoiles
les planètes et les comètes
c'est tout et donc il y avait très peu
de données ce qui n'a pas empêché
einstein d' élaborer sa théorie qui
continuent d'être valide malgré toutes
les données que nous avons accumulée
maintenant on peut s'amuser à faire une
histoire contrefactuelle s'était imaginé
que les choses se seraient déroulées à
l'envers imaginons que nous ayons toutes
les données recueillies depuis un siècle
par les satellites et les télescopes et
la question est est-ce qu'à partir de
ces données
nous pourrions retrouve
les équations d'einstein et la réponse
est non du point
c'est une réponse négative que einstein
aurait rapporté cette question je le
cite jour les guillemets il écrit à
maurice loving un de ses amis avec
lequel il avait fondé l'académie olympia
aucune méthode inductive ne peut
conduire aux concepts fondamentaux de la
physique
l'incapacité à le comprendre et la plus
grave erreur philosophique de nombreux
penseurs du 19ème siècle
fin de citation et donc comment skype
stein a procédé pour élaborer une
théorie sans donner mais il l'a fait
parce qu'on appelle des expériences de
pensée des cependant de penser c'est des
expériences qu'on peut imaginer qu'ils
invitent à s'écarter du réel empirique à
se transposer dans des sortes d'ailleurs
pour voir comment une théorie qu'on
suppose vrai impliqueraient certains
phénomènes dans une situation qu'on peut
imaginer
et enfin il a commencé à faire ça à
l'adolescence à l'âge de 15 ans il était
à munich dans un lycée à la discipline
militaire comme tous les lycées en
allemagne à l'époque il a démissionné
à 15 ans il rejoint ses parents en
italie et là ils étaient scolarisés
pendant plusieurs mois et écrit une
lettre à l'un de ses oncles dans
laquelle ils expliquent toutes les
questions qui vont l'intéressé tout au
long de sa vie et dans cette lettre il
raconte que les questions qui
l'intéressent sont les questions
relatives à la lumière et à sa
propagation dans l'espace les poses des
questions bizarres
qu'est-ce qui se passerait si de la
lumière et mettait de la lumière la
lumière balade des lumières et donc si
on a droit d'ajouter les vitesses comme
on le fait d'habitude la vitesse de la
lumière émise serait deux fois la
vitesse de la lumière
mais si la lumière émise et met à son
tour la lumière ça fait trois fois et
ainsi on fabrique un escalier
cinématiques vers l'infini est-ce que
c'est pas un problème
un an plus tard il est quand même à
nouveau scolarisés en suisse
dans un lycée qui le prépare au concours
polytechnique de zurich dans une école
beaucoup plus libérale qu'en allemagne
et là il fait l'expérience de pensée
dans laquelle il le fera souvent par la
suite il met en scène son propre corps
se pose la question qu'est ce que je
percevrai si j'étais à cheval sur un
rayon lumineux
à l'époque on sait que la lumière dont
on pense que la lumière est faite ondes
électromagnétiques et donc si je suis à
cheval sur un rayon lumineux jeu de me
déplace en même temps que l'undd
électromagnétiques
je fais du surf sur elle donc c'est
ondes par rapport à moi est immobile
donc je vois une ombre stationnaire aura
16 ans einstein savait déjà qu'il
n'existe pas de solution stationnaire
des équations de maxwell qui décrivent
la lumière donc de deux choses l'une où
cette expérience de pensée que j'ai
faite n'a aucun sens au sens où elle ne
correspond à aucune réalité possible ou
bien il ya un problème avec les
équations de maxwell
il va résoudre la question dix ans plus
tard il est à berne en 1905 l'année
miraculeuse centpapiers géniaux droit
sur la relativité restreinte darty de
juin 1905 dans lequel il dit que la
vitesse de la lumière est un invariant
elle est la même dans tous les
référentiels
elle est donc indépendante de la vitesse
de la source qu'il aimait et de la
vitesse de l'observateur qui la mesure
la vitesse de la lumière est aussi une
vitesse limite la baraque notre sujet
une particule ne peut pas la déplacer
d'ailleurs dans la g de la vitesse de la
lumière le dis déjà la vitesse de la
lumière à pour anagramme limite les
rêves au delà
en 1907 einstein est toujours à perdre
c'est toujours pas de postes
universitaires malgré le seul papier
extraordinaire qu'il a publié deux ans
plus tôt en rentrant déjeuner au mois de
novembre dans un rêve semi éveillé il
fait à nouveau une expérience de pensée
qui sera dit il plus tard
l'idée la plus heureuse de sa vie il
comprend quoi suffit de lire j'ai
compris qu'une personne en chute libre
ne sent pas son propre poids bizarre si
vous tombez sa cause de votre point qui
la cause de votre chute en maintenance
poids provoque d'autres chutes et
pendant que vous tombez tous les objets
qui tourne avec vous par exemple de
téléphone pas par rapport à vous ils
tombent plus puisque tous les corps
tombent à la même vitesse dans le vide
c'est ce qu'a montré galilée donc votre
téléphone qui tombe avez-vous vous
semble être en apesanteur
alors même que c'est la pesanteur qui
vous fait tomber bizarre il énonce ce
qui va appeler le principe d'équivalence
équivalence entre l'accélération et la
gravité est il dit simplement que si je
suis dans une cabine complètement fermée
il ya aucun hublot qui veut permettre de
voir l'extérieur
cette cabine sans que je sache moi qui
suis l'intérieur est posée à la surface
de la terre immobile dans le champ de
gravité terrestre première expérience
deux expériences la même cabine est loin
de tout objet massif et les en dehors de
tout champ de gravitation
simplement elle est accéléré par un
super héros avec une accélération égal à
l'accélération de la pesanteur
donc elle est accéléré dans le vide en
dehors de tout champ de gravitation
c'est la deuxième expérience et scuderi
stein sais que si je suis dans la cabine
il y a aucune expérience que je puisse
faire qui me permettent de se voir si je
suis dans la première situation dans la
seconde vie
elles sont équivalentes un an plus tard
deux ans plus tard plus tôt ils valent à
prague son premier post universitaire il
continue à réfléchir à tout cela il se
met dans la deuxième situation
la cabine est accélérée dans une
certaine direction avec une accélération
constante un trou et percer dans la
paroisse je regarde l'heure de la
lumière entre la lumière ne va pas
évident à sa fille donc elle met un
certain temps pour traverser la cabine
pendant ce temps là la cabine se déplace
dans l'espace et donc le point d'impact
de la lumière sur la paroi opposée n'est
pas exactement en vis-à-vis du point
d'entrée
il est un peu plus bas donc moi qui suis
dans la cabine je vois que la lumière
est courbé dans l'ascenseur c'est
simplement un effet d'accélération ça
tout le monde peut le comprendre
là où intervient le gie d'einstein elle
joue pas d'équation principe
d'équivalence ce que je vois dans la
cabine d'ascenseur accéléré c'est la
même chose que je verrai ce gt dans la
cabine qui mobile sur le sol donc si la
cabine était immobile sur le sol la
lumière serait dévié non pas par
l'accélération et par la gravitation
ce qui veut dire que la lumière bien que
n'ayant pas de masse subi la gravitation
d'einstein comprenant ça sent qu'ils
peuvent avoir besoin de changer la
géométrie l'espace temps d'utiliser un
espace-temps courbet pour tenir compte
de cet effet les trois ans plus tard il
aura écrit des équations de la
relativité générale suivie en 1915 qui
vont lui permettre de prédire des ondes
gravitationnelles dès 1916 donc la
morale de l'histoire c'est qu'une
théorie bien faite permet de faire
émerger des nouvelles données mais la
réciproque n'est pas vraie des données
ne permettent pas toujours de faire
émerger une théorie qui permet de les
comprendre
je vous laisse réfléchir là dessus je le
mets entre guillemets parce que c'est
une phrase qui a déjà été dit merci à
vous
[Applaudissements]